Speaker 1: I do want to spend a few minutes
covering the latest rantings from former President
Donald Trump.
As we learned this weekend and as we talked
about on yesterday's show, Donald Trump is
very much in control of a huge portion of
the Republican Party.
And Trump's agenda setting power is going
to influence how the Republican Party positions
itself for twenty, twenty two in 2022.
Joe Biden can get much done between now and
November of two, but those second two years
of Joe Biden's presidency are going to determine
the legacy of the administration in terms
of the totality of what gets done.
Now, Donald Trump, as you may know, has a
blog.
It was promoted as a new social media communications
platform, was going to be life changing revolutionary.
It turns out it's just a blog and the blog
posts read like tweets.
So this is kind of like sad trump Twitter.
As maybe we should call it, and over the last
48 hours, Donald Trump has published multiple
screeds to sad Trump Twitter and if they are
any indication about the likely direction
and focus of the Republican Party over the
next period of time, it's looking very humiliating.
And I'm unclear whether there's a strategy
here at all, never mind a potentially winning
strategy.
So let's jump right in.
Donald Trump starting out even Sunday's Mother's
Day, turning it into something political,
saying Happy Mother's Day to all.
It will all come back bigger and better and
stronger than ever before.
Do not worry.
Now the economy is doing as well as it has
done throughout the entire pandemic.
New stock market records.
Inflation remains low.
Vaccination is doing well.
Biden's popularity, 63 percent.
More than half the country thinks we're going
in the right direction.
So Trump is teasing that someday we'll get
back to things being good.
Things have improved dramatically since Donald
Trump left from then.
Trump going on to tweet that sorry to blog
about the Kentucky Derby, but very late saying
so.
Now, even our Kentucky Derby winner, Medina
Spirit, is a junkie junkie.
Why now?
That's yeah.
Anyway, that that's the wrong spelling, but
that's fine.
This is emblematic of what is happening to
our country.
The whole world is laughing at us as we go
to hell on our borders, our fake presidential
election.
He's still going with that and everything
else.
Then Trump attempting to weigh in on the Liz
Cheney situation once again.
And this relates to that pro versus anti Trump
split in the Republican Party that we talked
about in some detail yesterday.
Trump saying, quote, The House GOP has a massive
opportunity to upgrade this week from war
monger Liz Cheney to gifted communicator Elise
Stefanik.
Aleece has intelligence, an endorsement from
American patriot Brandon Judd and the National
Border Patrol Council.
She has an A plus from the NRA and she loves
our veterans.
We need someone in leadership who has experience
flipping districts from blue to red as we
approach the important twenty, twenty two
midterms.
And that's Elise.
She knows how to win, which is what we need.
Now, the theme here is cancel those who aren't
on message with the Republican Party.
These people claim to be against cancelation
and yet they are very quickly going to cancel
Romney, cancel Liz Cheney and Trump wanting
to play kingmaker for twenty twenty two, then
Trump issuing sort of like a political endorsement.
Also part of this, he wants to play kingmaker
narrative, saying, quote, Lt. Gov. Dan Patrick
is a great fighter for the people of Texas.
He has stood up for life, liberty, the Second
Amendment, border security, our military and
our vets and our God given freedoms.
He is governed by conservative principles
of low taxes and careful spending, always
doing what is best for his great state and
for America.
Texas should reelect him.
He is outstanding and has my complete and
total endorsement.
Now, Dan Patrick is one of the most disgusting
state level officials up there with Greg Abbott
from Texas.
And, you know, so many others, Kristi Noem
and so many others.
He's the guy who early in the pandemic said,
listen, grandma would sacrifice herself for
the economy by which he meant the stock market,
and it went downhill from there.
So Trump already aligning his endorsements
and they are of the worst, most horrible people.
Then Trump going after Mitt Romney continuing
the Republican Party split, saying after being
loudly booed at the Utah Republican Party
convention, Utah's Weber County censured RINO
Mitt Romney in the strongest of terms.
Washington County Republicans also censured
Romney in April.
He is bad news for our country.
Clearly, Trump will be involved in the twenty
twenty two election.
And then lastly, another one of these delusional
election fraud posts.
Trump writing the major Michigan election
fraud case has just filed a bombshell.
No, they haven't pleading claiming votes were
intentionally switched from President Trump
to Joe Biden.
The number of votes is massive and determinative.
This will prove true in numerous other states.
All Republicans must unify and not let this
happen.
If a thief robs a jewelry store of all its
diamonds, the twenty twenty election, the
diamonds must be returned.
The fake news media refuses to cover the greatest
election fraud in the history of our country.
They have lost all credibility, but ultimately
they will have no choice.
So he's still going and we could write it
off as just delusions.
But most of the Republican Party still believes
it, they still believe Joe Biden didn't really
win the 2020 election.
So the question is, can this work to win them
20 22?
It lost them to the house in twenty eighteen.
It lost them the Senate in 2020.
It lost them the White House in 2020.
Can it work in 2022 or is it destined to give
them the same disaster?
Let me know what you think we are doing a
one day huge membership special on Memorial
Day.
Want to be notified?
It's very easy.
Just get on my mailing list at David Pakman
dot com on Memorial Day, a glorious day.
You will get an email telling you exactly
how to take advantage of this incredible one
day membership special.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this.